MAN: Aah!
[phone rings]
SIMON: Guys! Guys! Crew!
It might be a callout!
[phone rings]
Hello, hello?
Yes, I can hear you.
You have a snake?
Okay, calm down, it's okay.
What color?
Yeah, what, black?
Gray?
Okay, you can't see all of it.
Okay, well, don't go near it.
Can you get someone just
to stand there and watch it?
Very important.
Do not move away from there,
and just get them to watch it.
And we'll be on our way, yes,
we'll come now, right now, yes.
Do me a favor,
SMS me your address,
it'll make things
quicker for us, too, okay.
And don't leave the snake, okay?
We're coming now,
okay, bye, bye.
Right, guys,
it's a possible callout.
He says it's big and it's black,
and he only saw half of it,
and it's gone outside.
So, we're going to need
to move it up.
Okay, ready?
♪ ♪
♪ Poison ♪
I'm Simon Keys.
That's my girlfriend,
Siouxsie Gillett.
We're professional
snake catchers.
For $30, you get rid
of an unwanted visitor,
we get to save a snake's life.
SIOUXSIE: I would never
change what I do. I love it.
SIMON: Our passion is to keep
the snakes alive.
♪ Poison, poison, poison ♪
Hello? Are you alright?
Got to you in the end,
alright, guys,
how are you, how are you,
Simon, how are you doing?
Simon and Siouxsie, alright.
Okay.
SIOUXSIE: Hey, I'm sorry
for the day, I'm Siouxsie.
Hi, pleased to meet you.
SIMON: Alright.
Nice to meet you.
SIOUXSIE: Oh, hello!
SIMON: Okay, get the little...
Go, go, doggie.
SIOUXSIE: Oh, okay.
SIMON: Oh, okay, right.
MAN: So I moved the car,
it's right...
SIMON: In those bricks?
Okay. And you say black?
MAN: It's black, like,
it just stood like this.
SIMON: Stood up.
Shiny back, or like a...?
MAN: Shiny.
SIMON: Okay.
MAN: Shiny black, yes.
SIMON: Alright, get the little
doggie out of here.
I'll tell you why,
if it bites the dog,
the dog's, the dog's history.
If it is,
if it is what we think it is.
I'll tell you what,
let's switch these glasses.
Give me some yellows.
When people say black snake
in this city,
it's most likely to be
one of five dark snakes,
and I need to be prepared
for any one of those.
One, a house snake,
or two, a herald snake,
both harmless to humans.
Three, a Mozambique
spitting cobra,
highly venomous and it can spit
its venom accurately
at your eyes from six feet away.
Four, a forest cobra.
It can't spit, but it has
a much more potent
and fast-acting neurotoxic venom
than the spitting cobra.
Or five, a black mamba.
A fast snake and a venomous bite
that can kill you in 30 minutes.
Did you see it in the middle bit
here, or this bit?
SIMON: Right.
Whoa, it's a lot of bricks.
Maybe best you just stand back,
just in case it's a mamba.
MAN: Yeah, because...
SIMON: Or the cobra,
it'll be fast.
SIOUXSIE: Have you pretty much
kept your eye on it,
that you know it's,
it hasn't come out, basically?
SIMON: Siouxsie's an experienced
snake handler,
but this is her first season
catching wild snakes.
SIOUXSIE: It'll be a case
of moving the brick.
I keep thinking my mum
is going to kill me
if she found out what I'm doing.
She thinks I'm sort of relaxing
and reading on the beach
while Simon's out here
working and catching snakes.
SIMON: It's really important
to Siouxsie, you know,
to get a grip with this
very quickly,
because, let's say something
goes wrong.
Say I get bitten,
and that snake's still loose,
she's got to catch it.
Can't just leave it.
We have to move,
it's about 400 bricks.
This is gonna take, you know...
SIOUXSIE: A while.
SIMON: Half an hour.
Well, basically,
it's gone behind here,
and obviously we can't pull it
out from the bottom.
We've got to go from the top
and work our way down.
So it's going to take time.
Hopefully the snake's behind
there, curled up somewhere.
A bit dodgy, because you can end
up getting a bite on the finger,
so I'm just doing little bit
by little bit.
You know, I don't want
to get bitten.
So, ooh, you see, geckos.
Anything that moves.
Have you got a bit here?
SIOUXSIE:
Just want to check this gap.
SIMON: My mind is racing.
It's a hot day today,
so whatever snake is in here
is going to be charged up
and ready to strike.
A black mamba could shoot out
and bite me on my legs,
a spitting cobra could
nail me in the eyes
before I even see it.
Okay.
Lots of eyes are
better than two,
so just watch me legs,
nothing comes shooting out.
SIOUXSIE: If it's that big,
that's what I'm thinking.
SIMON: If it is something
like a mamba or cobra,
all hell could break loose,
so just bear in mind
we might have to jump back,
these bricks might go flying.
So, now I'm going to pile bricks
there and on top of there,
so now I've got a clear exit
out there.
SIOUXSIE: You don't want
to brick yourself in, no.
SIMON: No, no. So, just in case.
I'm hoping to be see,
see behind here soon.
SIOUXSIE: There's a gap there,
can you see it?
SIMON: There is a little bit
of a gap there.
You ready with that grabber
if I call you?
SIOUXSIE: Ooh, I can see it!
There we go, a head.
SIMON: Where?
SIOUXSIE: There.
SIMON: Yep.
SIOUXSIE: Cobra.
SIMON: Forest cobra. Okay.
The forest cobra is the biggest
cobra in Africa,
reaching over eight feet
in length.
It's an alert and nervous snake,
therefore dangerous.
The fast-acting neurotoxic venom
attacks the central
nervous system,
paralyzing the muscles
that control breathing.
Untreated, you could be dead
within hours.
It's here.
Um, one glove, left. Ta.
Right, I need to,
I'm going to push these off.
I've got a feeling it might
get under the wall here.
Where are you going,
where are you going?
It's going to come out
this side, I think, so.
Where's your head?
Which end have I...
I think I've got the tail.
Just going to pull a little bit.
Right.
SIOUXSIE: Can I get in
with my hand to do the bricks?
SIMON: No, no,
don't touch the...
SIOUXSIE: No, no, no,
with the glove.
SIMON: Just get that brick there
out the way.
Okay, he's not going
anywhere now.
SIOUXSIE: So I can move
the brick with my hand?
SIMON: No, no,
not with your hand.
I've got the tail end, yeah,
put, yeah, use that hand.
I have kind of thrown Siouxsie
right in the deep end,
and she's probably thinking,
Christ, what's going on?
There's a lot going
through my head now,
I've got to pass him this,
grab that, put a glove on,
grab the tongs, grab the hook,
put the goggles on.
You know, it's like chaos.
SIOUXSIE: I do just hope
I'm quick enough
just to make sure
nothing happens to him.
I think in that situation
it is life or death.
SIMON: Lift that brick
up if you can.
Just, in you go. Oh, he's going.
I can't grip with these things.
Watch my leg.
SIOUXSIE: Yeah.
SIMON: Okay, that'll do.
SIMON: Right, it's coming out.
Okay, forest cobra.
[sighs]
Right, can you take these
glasses off my face?
I can't see what I'm doing.
Thank you. Right,
don't need them anymore.
Alright, that's a forest cobra.
It's probably about a year,
a year and a bit old,
year and a half old,
not much more than that.
These ones can't spit.
Just give me the other glove
on there for a second.
SIOUXSIE: Here?
SIMON: Yeah, yeah.
SIMON: Very dangerous snake,
neurotoxic venom,
that'll cause paralysis.
Serious stuff.
If he bites my finger,
it doesn't matter, I hope.
If you look at the tail there,
you see it's got quite a point
on the end of it?
SIOUXSIE: Oh, that's
the defense, isn't it?
SIMON: That's the defense.
So when I've got him like this,
he'll actually stick that tail
into my skin,
and people that are unaware
of that would actually drop it,
thinking they'd been bitten,
it's quite sharp.
SIOUXSIE: He's doing it now,
isn't he?
SIMON: Yeah,
he's doing it now.
It doesn't actually
break the skin.
But if you didn't know
about the snake,
you'd probably think
you've just been bitten,
if you grabbed it
willy-nilly, you know.
I think he's feeling
fairly relaxed now.
SIOUXSIE:
Yeah, he's quite calm.
SIMON: He's not too bad.
Like I say, you treat each one
individually.
I've caught some psychos, yeah,
he might have a go at my finger.
SIOUXSIE: Might have a bite now.
Look at that.
Do you trust those gloves?
That's what I'm saying.
SIMON: Only one way
to find out.
It should be alright.
SIOUXSIE: No, we don't want
to risk it, do we?
SIMON: So you guys,
you're scared of the snake?
MAN: Yeah.
SIMON: Yeah, it is
a dangerous snake.
No problem.
I think we need to get this
into a bag.
Maybe just put the towel
in between those two fingers.
SIOUXSIE: Mm-hmm.
SIMON: Now, what I'm going
to do, I'm going to put that...
No, no, no, no, no. Go on, then.
You've got a little bite there,
don't bite yourself, though.
Come here. He's having a go
on the glove.
SIOUXSIE: You want to keep him
off the glove?
SIMON: No, it's alright.
Oh, yeah, you really feel that.
SIOUXSIE: I hope it works.
SIMON: Okay, let go of him.
He'll be, yeah, better
to just let go.
Yeah, you can really feel
the pressure on the glove there
when they bite.
It's not a particularly pleasant
feeling,
I can be honest with you.
If that was your, if that was
on my skin now, bare skin,
I'd really be in big trouble.
SIMON: Push him into the bag.
SIOUXSIE: Right.
SIMON: You let go of the bag,
quickly.
Now he's in the bag.
SIOUXSIE: I'll get tape.
SIMON: Yeah, get the tape.
Push it all the way down.
Got gloves on,
so it's not dangerous.
SIOUXSIE: Watch your belly.
SIMON: Yeah, keep it away
from the old belly.
Twist, twist, twist,
all the way to the top.
Snake's right there,
can't do anything.
That's it, the snake's
in the bag.
Don't go near the bag.
The snake will bite you
through the bag.
SIOUXSIE: Now put all
the bricks back.
SIMON: And we'll...
Oh, yeah, no. That's their job.
SIOUXSIE: Help.
[laughs]
SIMON: I'll let them do that,
I think.
I've done my building course
for one day.
SIMON: Thanks, man.
MAN: Thanks, guys.
MAN: Thank you very much for
your help, thank you, thank you.
SIMON: No worries.
SIOUXSIE: No problem at all.
SIOUXSIE: Thank you very much.
Thank you. No, you take care.
Thank you, bye, take care!
SIMON: Just about all
of Africa's deadliest
and most dangerous snakes
are found here,
in Durban, South Africa.
Every day we drive for miles
across the city,
catching problem snakes
and releasing them
into nature reserves and bush,
in and around the city.
But today is different.
Our next callout is only
a few doors down.
We just got in the car and,
like, literally 30 seconds,
the security guy comes
screaming down the road
saying there's another big snake
just literally a minute
around the corner.
I thought he was just
having a joke,
you know, a bit of a laugh.
Can you believe that?
What the hell is
going on here today?
When your morning
starts out like this,
you know each callout is going
to get even crazier and crazier.
I had no idea how big and bad
today would get.
Crazy stuff.
When it goes, when it starts
happening, it starts happening.
You don't stop, you know.
Like, just grab stuff.
Okay. Here we go.
SIOUXSIE:
Oh, he's locked me in.
SIMON: Around the side?
MAN: Yeah.
SIMON: What color?
SIMON: Oh, yeah.
Another forest, quick!
It's getting away!
Where's it gone?
SIOUXSIE: I'm here,
I'm here with the gloves.
I can't see where you are.
SIMON: Sioux, quick!
SIOUXSIE:
I'll go the other way.
SIMON: Sioux,
he's coming your way.
SIOUXSIE: Whoa, whoa,
I can't see!
SIMON: Grab some tongs.
Watch out!
It's by your legs, guys.
Watch, it's coming out,
it's coming out.
SIOUXSIE: Where are you?
I can see where you are.
SIMON: There, there,
there, there.
Run in there.
SIOUXSIE: Run in there.
Okay, let me get grabbers.
SIMON: The forest cobra
has the upper hand,
you know, in the bushes,
in the trees.
So you see it for a second
and then it disappears.
Where's it, where's it?
Right, watch there. Sioux?
SIOUXSIE: I'm here
getting tools.
SIMON: Grab tongs?
SIOUXSIE: I'm getting tools,
I'm getting tools.
SIMON: Stay there. Went in here.
SIOUXSIE:
I've got no bag ready.
SIMON: It's gone in the bloody
tree, I missed it.
SIOUXSIE: Could you not
leave it here?
Is it not happy in this natural?
SIMON: No.
SIOUXSIE: Oh, it's someone's
garden. Okay.
SIMON: Yeah, I've just missed it
by a half a centimeter,
and now it's in here.
Right, can you watch that side?
SIOUXSIE:
We haven't got anything?
SIMON: No, you stay that side.
SIOUXSIE: Yeah.
SIMON: And I need someone.
Can you stay by the gate?
And just look up that
back section there.
So if he comes out,
then you can just shout,
and I'll try and get to it.
And also, look up
in the tree as well.
They climb super fast.
That just went past your leg,
right about missed you
by about two inches.
Close.
SIOUXSIE: Definitely
a forest, yeah?
SIMON: Yeah, yeah.
Do you not see it?
SIOUXSIE: I didn't see it.
I was running around getting
tubs and snakes and bags and...
SIMON: It was moving so fast,
but I just missed it
with the tongs.
And you know what?
It'll climb up this thing
so easy.
SIOUXSIE: This snake
can do anything.
It can climb,
it can stay on the ground,
but there is huge piles
of leaves,
so, for us, nature is
against us, with camouflage.
So it's hidden away.
So now it's just a case
of literally digging through
all these leaves
trying to find it.
SIMON: Alright, can you look
in the tree?
Just keep looking
up into the tree.
SIOUXSIE: So, now Simon's
telling me to keep looking up,
when obviously
we've looked already
around the ground,
dug through the leaves.
The key thing here is now,
I mean,
it literally is look everywhere,
up and down.
SIMON: It's in here somewhere,
but I don't know.
There's so much bush.
SIOUXSIE: And they're fast,
so it doesn't help us.
It's probably already...
SIMON: Watch your legs, guys.
This thing shot,
literally, in seconds.
SIOUXSIE: Do you want me
to go the other side?
SIMON: Go the other side, just
keep looking up in the trees.
You'll see it for a second,
then it disappears.
And the first time it was going
along the floor, just whoosh,
fast, fast, fast,
head up, moving around,
zipping along
like nobody's business.
Trying to get away, obviously.
I don't want to lose it,
so I'm running after it,
and I'm tripping
over twigs and branches,
hitting myself in the head,
you know, it's like, and as I go
to put the tongs on it,
I missed it by about an inch.
You know, a tiny amount
like that.
I thought, oh,
and then he's off.
The guy that we just did
the previous callout
with the bricks, he decided
to walk around the corner
to, you know, come and have
a look with his mate.
SIMON: Where, where, where?
Okay, keep an eye on it.
SIOUXSIE: This guy is good.
SIMON: Oh, yeah,
it's up the tree.
Okay, hold that.
SIOUXSIE: Where, where, where?
SIMON: Going up.
Keep an eye on it all the time,
until I get up the tree.
Hold that one sec.
Quick, quick, quick.
He's going that way.
SIOUXSIE: What are you
going to do?
SIMON: I don't know.
SIOUXSIE: Do you need a tool
up there? Tool and gloves?
I've got it, really high up.
What do you want, gloves?
SIMON: Give me the tongs.
Where is it now? Oh, yeah,
he's going to the other tree.
Just watch, don't take
your eyes off it.
[heavy breathing]
How can I get over there?
SIOUXSIE: What are
your plans, Simon?
Do you want me to be somewhere?
SIMON: I don't know.
Catch snake.
Just keep watching it.
Forest cobras are
excellent climbers.
Instead of the typical
serpentine movement
of the lateral S-bends,
they also use a concertina-like
movement in the trees.
They contract muscles that pull
its specialized belly scales
forward,
the back edge of these scales
catching on the bark.
Using other muscles,
it then pushes these scales
against the bark, propelling
the whole body forward.
Ooh, he's going faster
than I can go.
SIOUXSIE: Where's it going?
SIMON: Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Ah, he's in the tree here,
I missed him again.
Look, just keep looking there.
SIOUXSIE: I've got him,
I've got him, I can see him.
SIMON: Where is it?
SIOUXSIE: Right, it's just
in the gap between the trees,
the two dead bits of leaves
at the top.
He's going to cross now.
He's literally, his tail's
going in that gap.
SIMON: Where?
SIOUXSIE: Right, see that bunch
of dead leaves,
opposite that bit.
SIMON: I can't see it.
SIOUXSIE: You can't see it?
Now I've lost him,
he's gone in that, though,
all that collection
of dead leaves,
opposite the bit you're in.
He's gone in there.
SIMON: In there?
SIOUXSIE: Yeah.
SIMON: Bugger!
There's nothing else
to stand on here.
Venom from the bite
of a forest cobra
moves through the human body
much faster
than many other species
of venomous snake.
The attack on the nervous system
may affect muscle control
in minutes,
not something you want
15 feet up in a tree.
SIOUXSIE: Can you shake it?
SIMON: No, because
I could fall out.
Alright, I missed again.
SIOUXSIE: Watching Simon
up the tree
trying to catch the cobra,
it's very hard to watch,
and I think, you know, it is
like watching your partner
have a gun held to their head.
It's a very serious situation.
I don't think that looks safe.
SIMON: Watch my head.
[branches breaking]
Oh, fricking hell.
SIOUXSIE: Can you grab?
SIMON: Oh.
SIOUXSIE:
Right, are you alright?
SIMON: It wasn't going well
for me.
No, not at all.
Siouxsie?
SIOUXSIE: I'm here.
What are you doing?
SIMON: I've got a grab on it,
but it's in the wrong spot.
I'm in the top of the tree now,
and I've got the snake,
and I've got to make a decision.
I've got the cobra in one hand
with the tongs,
I'm holding on with the other.
The branches are very thin,
they're bending and tipping
all over the place.
I can't get a very good grip.
So I'm thinking maybe I will
just pass it to Siouxsie,
she can deal with it.
I don't know if that was
the right thing to do or what.
You know, sorry, darling,
you know, here,
just deal with this
meter-long forest cobra.
SIMON: Whoa, whoa, whoa!
It's going again.
SIOUXSIE: Where we going?
Where we going? I can't see.
SIMON: It's falling down!
SIOUXSIE: Down, down, down.
SIMON: Sioux, there, quick!
SIOUXSIE: I can't,
I'm too short, too short!
SIOUXSIE: Watch your leg!
Watch your leg!
SIMON: Where'd it go?
There, it's on the floor! Quick!
Just grab it anywhere, anywhere.
Have you got it?
SIOUXSIE: Not yet, not yet.
SIMON: Quick, quick,
quick, quick!
SIOUXSIE: Oh, blast it.
SIMON: The fricking thing.
SIOUXSIE:
I got--no, it's going.
SIMON: Where's it gone?
Have you got it?
SIOUXSIE: I've got the tail
and that's it.
SIMON: Just hold it down,
I'm coming.
Coming down, guys,
I'm gonna jump down.
SIOUXSIE: I don't know
where it's gone.
I can't see, I've got the tip
of the tail.
Down there, down there.
Oh, yeah, I've got a bit of it.
Watch yourself, watch yourself.
SIMON: Where'd it go?
Not again!
SIOUXSIE: This thing
is bloody good.
SIMON: Damn.
Now where's it gone?
Damn the thing.
Stay there.
Bastard.
SIOUXSIE: There was a time
at one point I saw it come down
and actually get
next to Simon's ankle.
I actually did think he bit him
at one point,
from the angle I could see,
it was very, very close.
Um, and you know, you do,
it's, you know,
your natural human emotion
is that it's, your loved one's
up a tree
being potentially bitten
by a cobra.
That's a really awful,
awful situation to be in.
SIMON: Yeah, I was a bit
concerned about that,
to be honest with you.
SIMON: Well, I've missed it
three times.
The snake has got the upper hand
here, because they're so agile.
I think it's gone deep
into that palm tree there.
I think if I don't dig it out
in the next couple minutes,
we'll have to just
leave it here.
SIOUXSIE: In the middle,
literally.
SIMON: Where?
SIOUXSIE: Where, where, where?
SIMON: Where, where, where?
SIMON: Where?
MAN: There, there, right by you.
SIMON: Where is it?
SIOUXSIE: Right--oh!
SIOUXSIE: There.
SIMON: Where?
SIOUXSIE: Bloody leaves!
I've got some of it.
Have you got it?
SIMON: Yep.
Right, glove, please.
SIOUXSIE: Here! Left hand?
SIMON: Left hand, quickly!
SIOUXSIE: Left hand.
SIMON: I've got right hand.
SIOUXSIE: You want right hand?
SIMON: Right hand.
SIOUXSIE: Right hand, go.
SIMON: Left hand.
SIOUXSIE: Go, go.
SIMON: Watch out, left hand.
SIOUXSIE: Yep.
SIMON: Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Let's get out here a bit,
let me just...
SIOUXSIE: Can you grab it a bit?
SIMON: You little bugger,
oh, gave me the run around.
Let him settle down
for a minute.
There we just go like that.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
Hey, hey, oh, oh, oh.
Thank you.
SIOUXSIE: There we go.
SIMON: There we go.
SIOUXSIE: That was good.
SIMON: Oh, you're cheeky.
Both of us nearly had you
twice, three times.
He's having a good bite there.
SIOUXSIE: Where's your
right hook?
Just in case we don't...
SIMON: No, he's alright,
he's just...
SIOUXSIE: I just don't trust
these gloves.
SIMON: No, they're alright.
Yeah, they can zip
through those trees so well.
You can't see them.
SIOUXSIE: Twice now!
MAN: Yeah.
SIMON: Twice in ten minutes.
An hour.
Twice in an hour.
Crazy.
A little bit smaller than
the other one, I think.
Yeah, a little bit smaller.
Just as dangerous, though.
Crazy.
Come on, let go, let go.
No, it's holding on.
Okay, this is a forest cobra.
A bit smaller than the previous
one, just as dangerous,
and very agile on the floor
and the trees.
So, it's terrestrial
and arboreal.
And it glides
through those trees
way faster than I could climb
up and down.
A couple of times I nearly fell
out, hanging on with one hand.
I pinned it behind the head,
didn't have a glove
on the other hand.
I just going to,
do I grab it with my hand?
I just wasn't feeling
comfortable with it,
I was losing the grip anyway.
Then it got away again,
then it went down,
then Sioux managed to grab it
by the tail,
and it still managed
to slip through.
That's the problem
with these gloves,
although they might save you
from a bite,
you don't get a good grip.
You can check, like,
the underneath.
SIOUXSIE: So here we've got
the belly scales here.
If you see how they lift, that
is actually how they grip on,
that's how they're able to climb
trees, purely because of this.
Oh, the tail got me there,
made me jump.
SIMON: Yeah, see.
SIOUXSIE: Yeah, see,
that's the defense, it works.
SIMON: It's like
a scorpion tail there.
SIOUXSIE: So, yeah, so he's
digging me with the tail there,
that's the defense.
You can see it's a real sharp
point on the end there,
and that's the bit, as I say,
is their defense.
You think you're being bitten,
and obviously I just
reacted as well.
But, yeah, it's these
belly scales.
SIMON: Can you get him
off my thing?
'Cause there's a lot
of pressure going on there.
SIOUXSIE: Okay.
SIMON: I don't like that.
SIOUXSIE: At one point, when
the cobra was biting
on Simon's glove, he did ask me
to release the grip.
Like, oh, my God,
maybe it has gone through.
SIMON: You can feel that
scratching, biting,
chewing noise,
and you can see the venom
sort of pouring out there
from the fangs.
He would have put a lot
of venom into me,
because he wasn't happy at all.
That's it. Okay.
Maybe if I just slide
back up a bit.
Is he alright? Yep.
SIOUXSIE: Yeah, yeah.
So go, move up, try and get
behind the head.
SIMON: And do it again?
SIOUXSIE: Mm-hmm.
SIMON: Yeah, I just felt like
my finger was getting hurt.
SIOUXSIE: Ooh, it's getting
close. Are you alright?
SIOUXSIE: Can you move up?
SIMON: What do I do?
SIOUXSIE: Swap hands, try--
let me grab the body.
SIMON: Hey, hey, hey, hey.
SIOUXSIE: Yeah,
if I grab the body.
SIMON: Right there.
SIOUXSIE: I've got the body.
SIMON: I don't think
it's gone through,
but it's not a pleasant feeling,
I'll be honest with you.
SIOUXSIE: Should we check?
SIMON: Yeah, in a minute.
SIMON: Very muscular snake, too,
and very, very fast.
SIOUXSIE: But beautiful
condition, really stunning.
SIMON: Yes, very good condition.
SIOUXSIE: Brilliant.
SIMON: Perfect. Okay.
SIOUXSIE: Bag it.
SIMON: Bag it.
SIMON: That's alright,
not gonna do anything.
One, two, three.
SIOUXSIE: Okay.
SIMON: That's it.
That'll do.
SIOUXSIE: Right.
Contained.
SIMON: Thank you, guys.
Hopefully we won't see you
again today.
Right, Sioux,
let's go find somewhere
to release these snakes.
SIOUXSIE: See you later.
MAN: Thank you very much.
SIMON: Stay safe.
SIOUXSIE: Thank you, bye.
SIMON: It's a hot day today,
which means the snakes
in this city will be warmed up
and on the hunt.
It's going to get crazy busy
and even more intense,
so we'd better release
these forest cobras quickly
before the next calls come in.
[phone rings]
♪ ♪
WOMAN: Thank you very much.
SIMON: Thank you.
[woman screams]
♪ ♪
Hey, right there.
[phone rings]
Hello?
A green snake?
Okay, we're on our way.
Just received a call.
A very mixed up conversation.
A green snake outside,
that's all we know.
You know, when you're catching
green snakes,
you've got to be very careful,
because there are about
five or six different types
of green snakes, so you don't
want to get it wrong.
You know, it could be
a bush snake.
That's harmless.
It could be a natal green.
Western green snake, harmless.
Green water snake, harmless.
Boomslang, dangerous.
Green mamba, deadly.
You know, it's like,
what do I do?
SIOUXSIE: Hiya,
you alright then?
SIMON: Hi, you alright?
SIOUXSIE: You're locking up.
SIMON: Yeah. Snake still there?
MAN: You can see.
SIOUXSIE: Is it still there?
Do you know what it is?
Can you identify it?
MAN: Green.
SIOUXSIE: It's green. Okay.
SIMON: You've got to look
at the head of the snake
to be able to tell
the difference,
and get a, you know, try and
decide as fast as possible.
Green mamba has got
a long, elongated face.
It almost looks like
it's doing this...
sucking its cheeks in.
It's got a line, you'll see it,
a big smiley face,
like an anvil-shaped head.
If I grab it, or tell
Siouxsie to grab it,
and it turns out to be
the wrong snake,
that could be disastrous.
SIMON: I can't see
anything yet.
SIOUXSIE: I can't see it.
SIMON: Oh, there it is.
Down there, down there,
see that little green snake?
SIOUXSIE: Oh, yeah, yeah,
I got it.
SIMON: The green water snake
has no venom glands
and is harmless to humans.
But it looks almost identical
to a baby green mamba,
which happens to be deadly.
Green mamba's neurotoxic venom
is chemically similar
to the venom of its
more famous cousin,
the black mamba,
but much less toxic.
Despite that, even a bite
from a 15-inch-long hatchling
can cause a heart attack
and respiratory arrest
in an adult human.
SIOUXSIE: What is it?
SIMON: I don't know, wait there.
SIMON: So we locate
the green snake,
and I've got to make
a decision now,
is it a safe snake or
is it a dangerous snake?
SIOUXSIE: The herpetologist's
way to do it
is to do a head scale count,
check how many scales
on the head, between the eyes.
We have no time for that.
We haven't got time to sit there
and count and judge what it is,
you know, we have to
grab it quick,
and especially this snake,
it was really, really fast.
SIMON: It's so fast,
it actually made a gap that way.
SIOUXSIE: In this situation,
for me, it's really,
really hard.
I have to rely completely
on Simon's judgment.
SIMON: Pull this table out,
move it right the way
out the way, over to here.
SIOUXSIE: Where is it?
I can't see it.
SIMON: Behind there.
That is weird.
SIOUXSIE: How strange.
SIMON: It's just disappeared
into nowhere.
You'll see it one second,
and then it's gone again,
and I didn't even see the head,
I could just see
the body go, 'bwwmmm!'
Oh, no, where's it gone?
Where's it gone?
I thinking, oh, is it a mamba?
You know, they are fast.
SIOUXSIE: Green mambas
are really fast.
So based on those factors,
looking at the snake,
my thought is it, well,
you know, it could be a mamba.
SIMON: I'm going to dig
around a bit.
If it comes out,
and I say grab, grab.
If I don't say grab,
don't grab it.
SIOUXSIE: You don't know
what it is, do you?
SIMON: No, it's a natal green.
Just got to be 100% sure.
SIOUXSIE: What do you say,
is it 100%?
SIMON: I'm 90%.
SIOUXSIE: Okay, I don't like
that 10% difference.
SIMON: Ooh, okay.
SIOUXSIE: His head poked
out the net.
Ooh, he's going up, going up,
going up, going up, yeah.
SIMON: Wait, wait, wait.
I just want to double check
it isn't one.
No, you're fine.
Wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, yep.
Here we go.
It is right,
it is a natal green,
but just got to check
for a smiley face.
You've only got a second
to make a decision
whether to grab it or not.
SIOUXSIE: You're happy?
SIMON: Yeah, yeah. We can have
a closer look at it in a second.
SIMON: Oh. Ugh.
SIOUXSIE: Must.
SIMON: Smell that.
SIOUXSIE: Lovely.
SIMON: That's really pleasant.
After a while I managed to get
a look at the head of it,
and I'm saying to Sioux,
no, it's a green water snake
or a natal green snake,
grab it if it goes your way,
and then I can see her going,
are you sure it's not a mamba,
are you sure?
And I thought to myself,
I better make sure again,
hadn't I?
So I'm looking
for the head again,
and I'm fishing around,
and then I saw it.
Yeah, good to go, and then
it shot my way and I grabbed it.
Yeah, it's a natal green,
a water snake.
Beautiful green snake, I'll get
it back out the bag now.
You know, you just got
to make sure
before you grab any green snake,
they do really resemble
a green mamba.
The only thing that's lacking
is a big, smiley mouth.
So you can see there, it doesn't
have the lips, you know,
like the green mamba,
potentially like that.
This little snake
doesn't have that.
SIOUXSIE: Pretty.
SIMON: Yeah, very pretty snake,
very fast moving,
and can disappear, as you saw
there, in half a second.
We didn't even know
where it went.
Familiarize yourself with that.
Sometimes they've got more
of a blue speckling on him.
SIOUXSIE: I'd say there is,
isn't there, here.
SIMON: Yeah.
That's a nice snake to catch,
we don't catch many.
He'll get about twice that size.
About as thick as your second
finger, something like that.
SIOUXSIE: Come on,
I'm holding it.
You're fine. I've got the head
so nothing can happen to you.
So have a touch,
he feels beautiful.
Are you okay?
You alright there?
Are you going to have a go?
[laughs]
SIMON: That's alright.
You did the right thing.
You just keep an eye on it.
SIOUXSIE: Okay, see,
you've got it, it's on you.
You're brave.
I've got the head, don't worry.
SIMON: To the untrained eye,
the harmless green varieties
generally get killed on site
because people think it's
a green mamba, which is sad.
So it was quite nice
to capture this one
and get it off to safety.
♪ ♪
We release every single
snake we catch.
I get a great feeling afterwards
when I've let a snake go,
and I see it disappear
into the bush,
and I hope I don't see it again.
♪ ♪
SIOUXSIE: So is there some,
a pond you've got,
you know about, in here?
SIMON: Yeah, yeah,
it's the perfect place for it.
Yeah, see, it's right here.
SIOUXSIE: Oh, it's perfect.
SIMON: Yep, there's frogs
in here, there's fish in here,
there's all sorts in here.
SIOUXSIE: He'll be really happy,
won't he?
SIMON: Yeah, yeah,
he'll be fine.
I've let loads of snakes
go here.
SIOUXSIE: Have you?
SIMON: Yeah, over the years.
SIOUXSIE: So, this is man-made,
is it?
SIMON: It's a man-made pond
in a nature reserve.
Over here will do.
SIOUXSIE: Just over there, yeah?
SIMON: Perfect.
[phone ringing]
I haven't got nails.
Hello?
Black mamba.
We'll be there
as fast as we can.
We have to let this thing
go now, and then go.
Okay, we're on our way,
okay, okay?
Yeah, cheers.
Text me the address.
Right, bye, bye, bye.
We have to go do this,
let it go.
Put it down there and let's go.
You alright, get the lid off?
SIOUXSIE: Ready?
SIMON: Bye-bye, snake.
SIOUXSIE: Just leave it
and do it?
SIMON: Yeah, yeah, let him go.
SIOUXSIE:
Perfect, look at him.
SIMON: There we go.
SIOUXSIE:
Yeah, oh, look how fast he is.
SIMON: Yeah, there you go.
Perfect swimmer, bye-bye.
SIOUXSIE: Yeah, he's quick.
That's really good.
Right, mamba.
SIMON: Right, let's go. Mamba.
♪ ♪
SIMON: It doesn't matter
how many times
you catch a black mamba,
it is always that thing of fear,
excitement, adrenaline,
and worrying, you know,
if you cock up,
could this be the last one
you catch?
That goes through your mind
all the time.
The best snake catchers
in the world get bitten.
It's just one of those jobs,
you know.
I think if it didn't,
if you didn't think like that,
you wouldn't be normal.
♪ ♪
[phone ringing]
The owner of the house
is freaking out,
asking where we are.
[phone ringing]
Yeah, just, just keep
an eye on the snake,
don't interfere with it,
and we'll be there
as quick as we can.
♪ ♪
Where am I parking?
Oh, there? Yeah.
SIOUXSIE: Do you have
the grabbers?
SIMON: No, that's it.
Okay.
This house here?
SIOUXSIE:
Did you lock the door?
SIMON: Yeah.
How's it, guys?
MAN: Good.
SIMON: Right.
SIMON: Oh, thanks.
Right, show me where.
MAN: Between this,
it's facing that way.
SIOUXSIE: Hiya,
are you alright?
MAN: It's standing
with the tail.
SIMON: Gray, black snake,
yeah? Big?
SIMON: Like a whiter color?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, okay.
SIOUXSIE: A mamba, yeah?
SIMON: So, yeah.
Okay, we're here now.
A black mamba's got inside.
Obviously there's a lot of stuff
going on in there.
There's potatoes everywhere,
there's fridges pulled out,
and it's gone behind
one of the cupboards here.
So, I'm just going to go in now
and take it from there, right?
SIOUXSIE: So they think--oh,
my God, I can't see anywhere.
They think it's behind the door?
SIMON: Yeah, somewhere up there.
Doesn't matter how many times
you catch a mamba,
your adrenaline is
always pumping.
There's so much going through
your head at the time,
and the situation,
and so many things that could
possibly go wrong.
And you are dealing with one of
the fastest snakes in the world,
probably the most feared snake
in the world.
The black mamba is not a toy,
it is one serious snake.
The black mamba's potent venom,
plus the massive amount
it injects,
makes for a deadly bite.
Its venom is both neurotoxic
and cardiotoxic,
meaning it affects
the entire nervous system
as well as the heart.
Initially there will be pain and
numbness around the bite site,
swiftly followed
by headaches, drooling,
nosebleeds, vomiting,
and diarrhea.
Paralysis follows,
including a lack of ability
to blink or swallow.
The lungs stop functioning.
Then the heart stops.
So you last saw it on the floor
or the top?
SIMON: Okay, alright,
let's just make a bit of...
Yeah, alright, let's just
make a bit of space.
This thing, wants to move it,
move it.
SIOUXSIE: Let me get
the torch ready.
SIMON: Get one torch out.
Okay.
Okay. Can't see anything.
It's not under there.
MAN: Now he's up there again.
SIMON: Went up there?
SIMON: Okay, in, inside?
Inside the wardrobe?
Okay, alright, alright.
When you're dealing with a
black mamba in a confined space,
like a wardrobe,
you know, you can't just go
sticking your hands in.
You don't know where it is,
maybe there's a lot of stuff
in the wardrobe.
It's not a case of just
taking everything out
and waiting for it to come out.
You know, you just don't know
what's going to happen,
you know?
It's one of the fastest
snakes in the world.
Siouxsie, if I grab it, you must
just bang another grabber
on midsection, anywhere.
Anywhere you can, but not,
obviously, too close
to where I'm going to put mine.
SIOUXSIE: If we're relying on
this person's description,
you know, it's a lot to rely on,
because if we're walking around
and the snake isn't
in the wardrobe,
potentially we're going
to tread on it,
or it's going to fly out,
you know, at us.
So it's really,
really dangerous.
SIMON: Behind it?
SIMON: There?
MAN: Yeah, yeah.
SIMON: There's nothing there.
SIMON: It might still be
in the cupboard, though.
MAN: Inside the bathroom.
SIMON: Inside the bathroom,
in here?
MAN: Yeah.
SIMON: Not in here. Not there.
Maybe it's still
inside the wardrobe?
MAN: Yeah.
SIMON: Yeah.
SIOUXSIE: I'll keep an eye
on this side.
SIMON: Yeah, just watch there.
No, here, here, here, here!
Right, it's huge.
SIOUXSIE: A mamba? Black mamba?
SIMON: Big black mamba.
Mama. Great, get another
grabber, quick.
And I just see
this big banana shape
of black, thick, thick, thick,
whoa, that's a big black mamba.
Two. Bang one on there.
SIOUXSIE: Where? There?
SIMON: Anywhere.
There, wait, it's gone through
the coat hanger, maybe,
let go of it, let him come out.
let go, let go.
SIOUXSIE: Oh, it's a good size.
SIMON: Stand up on that bed.
It's going down.
I'm going to move the snake
onto that there, okay, if I can.
Watch yourself.
Right, it's still
in the cupboard.
Where's it going, where's it
going, where's it going?
Where's it going?
SIOUXSIE: Right.
It's contained this side.
SIMON: Just keep an eye
out that side, guys,
'cause I can't see
behind this wardrobe.
Where's it gone?
Grab me a torch.
[gasps]
Watch out.
Whoa, okay, it's striking now.
Don't need the torch,
put it on the bed.
He means business, this one.
Okay.
Very slowly, slowly.
Yeah, you open your mouth.
Wha! Like this big flash
of black mouth,
sticks his head
out the wardrobe,
it's like, hey,
hang on a minute.
SIOUXSIE: You see the mouth,
the animal that delivers
the kiss of death,
and it's staring at me.
And do you of sort of think,
what the hell am I doing here,
why am I doing this?
SIMON: I need a torch.
It's going mental.
Quickly, get that thing on.
No, no, oh, not flashing.
SIOUXSIE: Blimey.
SIMON: In a confined space
like that,
you've got to be quick
to get out the way,
and even faster to try
and get a tong on it,
to get a grab stick on it fast.
And it's not easy to do that,
you know.
Firstly, for Sioux,
it's quite hard for her,
because she's got tiny hands,
like, her hands fit in the palm
of my hand.
She's got kid's hands.
Look at my hands, they're huge.
I can use the tongs
with one hand.
SIOUXSIE: Let's get gloves.
SIMON: So I see Siouxsie lifting
up the tongs like this,
and trying to go for it.
And I'm saying just grab
the bloody thing!
Put a grab stick on there,
just as quick as you can,
just hold it anywhere,
it doesn't matter.
Bang another grab,
bang another grab.
Quick, bang another grab.
Get it on there, get it
on there, get it on there.
SIOUXSIE: It's on there.
It's not good, hold on.
SIMON: Just get one on it.
SIOUXSIE: I am, I am, I am.
On.
SIMON: Keep that tight.
Don't let go, whatever you do.
SIOUXSIE: Tight.
SIMON: Letting go.
Don't let go, don't let go.
SIOUXSIE:
I'm not letting go.
SIMON: Now, you can let go,
in a second.
SIOUXSIE: Have you got
a good grip?
SIMON: Yeah, I've got it,
I've got it, okay, let go.
SIOUXSIE: You've got it? Happy?
Oh, that's big.
[whistles]
SIMON: Big black mamba.
[laughs]
This is a good...
I'd have to measure it,
but hold the tail there.
It's a big, old...
[whistles]
It's just scenting all over you,
watch out.
Just let him do that. Right.
That's probably getting close to
3 meters, I would say, 2.6, 2.7.
Would have to measure it,
but anyway it's big.
Let's move outside.
SIOUXSIE: Tools there.
SIMON: Need to bring
the tools.
Come back and get them.
Just reel it out, we'll come
back and get the tools.
Tail it out, tail it out.
Okay.
If you run back and
get the grabbers.
Run back and get the grabs.
SIOUXSIE: I let all that go.
SIMON: Nine, ten-foot snake.
Pumped up, very warm,
angry, upset,
and most importantly,
very, very scared.
This is obviously the most
dangerous part for us,
because if you slip,
then you got a big problem.
You've got something in your
hand that is potentially lethal,
and you need to get it
into that bag.
So it's very, very important
you don't mess this up.
It's not an easy thing to do.
You can't just shove your arm
in a pillowcase
and then just sort of, like,
go like that and it goes in.
It doesn't,
it doesn't work like that.
Alright, alright.
All we need is a pillowcase.
Okay, what I'm going to do...
Everyone just stay back, okay?
And don't touch the snake
or anything like that,
because this is very dangerous,
what I'm about to do.
SIMON: Put my other arm into
the pillowcase, into the corner.
Don't go anywhere near that.
SIOUXSIE: No, no, no.
SIMON: Just hold that there
for a second.
SIOUXSIE: Do you want me
to hold it?
SIMON: Just hold it, yeah,
just hold that for a second.
I'll do it after, that's fine.
Okay, so I've got the
black mamba in my right hand,
and somehow I've got to get it
into the pillowcase,
which will be in my left hand.
It's very hard to explain, but
basically what you've got to do
is you've got to feed
the pillowcase
underneath the black mamba,
touching your hand
with the snake,
and gradually,
and very, very slowly,
you have to exchange hands.
So now the snake was
in my right hand,
and now it needs to
be in my left hand,
with the pillowcase around it.
Very fiddly thing to do.
If you haven't got
the snake correctly,
it can turn and bite,
turn and bite you.
Contort its head, its face,
and it will get you.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Tail.
Just unravel it.
Alright, snake, I'm going
to get you out of here.
You know, what you're doing
is a dangerous job.
It's like being a bomb disposal
expert, you know?
It must go through their minds
as well, you know,
if I cut the wrong wire, am I
just going to see a big flash
and that's the end of me?
It's the same type of thing.
If you get bitten
by a black mamba,
you could be, you might be lucky
and get to hospital,
you might be dead in five,
ten minutes, you know.
It is really one
of those situations.
And you think, you've got
this snake behind the head,
it's fearing for its life,
it's going to inject you with
however much it can, you know,
it's not going to be
a small dose,
it's going to pump you
full of that [bleep],
and then you're in big trouble.
Chuck all that, pull that
all the way down.
Chuck it all in, chuck it in.
Chuck it all in, chuck it
all in, chuck it all in.
SIOUXSIE: It's in.
SIMON: Put it all in.
That looks good.
SIMON: Right, you're going
to put that on the floor.
SIOUXSIE: Do you want gloves
on this?
SIMON: No, no. Just get the bar,
no, get the grabber.
Just get a...
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Push it there on the floor,
flatten it.
Push it all the way.
SIOUXSIE: It could still jump,
though.
SIMON: Yeah.
Come on, get down.
See all that on the pillowcase
there, guys?
That's venom.
There's a bit of blood as well.
There's an injury to the snake,
I think.
Do you guys, did anyone
hit the snake or anything
when it went inside?
No one? Nothing? Okay.
Good.
You did the right thing not to.
Can you now get the tape,
just twist it round
as far as you can.
Keep going, keep going.
Pull, pull the sack as well,
at the same time.
The tighter the better, tighter.
SIOUXSIE: Is that,
just like that?
SIMON: No, no, I've got
his head there.
SIOUXSIE: No, I know.
I've got him by the tail.
SIMON: No, no. Tape it.
SIOUXSIE:
Yeah, can you hold it?
SIMON: Tape that.
SIOUXSIE: Lower?
SIMON: Just go around
a few times.
Remember, I've still
got his head.
Can't let go of the head.
If you let go of the head,
it will bite you
straight through the bag,
so that's the last thing you do,
is release the head.
Okay, move out the way.
One, two, three.
SIOUXSIE: Woo!
SIMON: Don't, no one touch
the bag, okay?
It'll bite you through the bag.
It'll still kill you,
no problem.
And then what we'll do...
Just leave that one. There.
Give me that other grab.
There. Watch your fingers.
Well done.
Dangerous.
That's it.
SIOUXSIE: Right. Contained.
SIMON: Okay, safe.
Snake's contained,
everybody's safe,
and then you can relax
for half a second.
You know, you can calm down
to panic mode now.
You know, after doing that,
you think to yourself,
I must be bloody nuts.
Yeah, that's from gripping...
So you were inside
when the snake came in?
SIMON: Yeah, I bet you
got a fright, eh?
[laughter]
SIMON: I'd also jump
through the window, don't worry.
That's very dangerous.
SIOUXSIE: Imagine putting
your hand in to get something
out the wardrobe...
SIMON: Yeah, imagine you went to
put your shirt on or something.
Obviously there are black mambas
around here,
but it's not that often
that they come inside.
They're generally outside.
But luckily you didn't
try to hit it,
because that big snake like that
could probably bite you
two or three times,
and then you're finished.
And it's hospital, and if you
don't get to hospital quick,
you're dead.
Sometimes 10, 15 minutes.
It's enough.
Very, very dangerous snake,
that one.
SIOUXSIE: Yeah.
SIMON: So, yeah, thanks for not
killing it either.
We'll take it away,
and we'll find it somewhere
where there's no people.
Okay. Cool, man. Nice one.
SIOUXSIE: Alright, cheers.
Thank you.
SIMON: I'll take the box.
Okay, set? Yeah, I will.
Okay, let's go.
SIOUXSIE: Thank you.
SIMON: Thank you, guys.
SIOUXSIE: Bye! Bye!
SIMON: Sorted.
ALL: Bye!
SIOUXSIE: Bye!
MAN: Love you!
[laughs]
SIMON: It's a good feeling,
you know.
Get the snake out of there,
the snake's fine,
the people are fine,
we are all fine.
And go home and sort
of just think about
what you've just done.
You know, it does sink in later.
You think, Jesus,
that was dangerous.
Well done.
Okay, bye.
Yeah, yeah.
Cool, yeah.
Okay, bye.
KIDS: Bye!